sofia bernard après votre conseil de
classe vous êtes sortis très énervé
contre kelly pourquoi voulez qu'on voit
la vidéo
ouais allez on y croit oui alors
meilleurs élèves pour moi c'est gégé
pour moi ça a toujours été une des
meilleures élèves français par un
honneur venant de ma part mais en tout
cas pour moi c était une des meilleures
et plus mauvais élèves c'est bernard
montiel mais vraiment sans hésiter sus
boules de la terre n'en portera sais pas
quoi dire sur des mots qui sort de nulle
part de son cerveau il est insupportable
gym c'est vraiment le plus nul
vous savez pourquoi parce que ça s'est
mal passé tout à l'heure en loge mais
voulait mais quand même mais j'adore
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai que j'ai été
très énervé c'est pourquoi parce que
j'ai une tendresse particulière pour
kelly et vous là qui fait je laime
beaucoup c'est vraiment ma petite soeur
c'était de la van meeuwen sûreté laval
mais sur le coup j'ai tellement été
surpris si vous voulez mais tellement
que vous avez dit oui mais pas elle
j'étais tellement sur yon et et casting
est encore pire
mais alors kelly non je laime et ça m'a
profondément blessé bêtement je
reconnais j'ai une tendresse
particulière pour elle mais c'est vrai
j'étais très énervé déçu et triste même
année d'ange et rebelle m'a appelé toute
la soirée le m'envoyer pleinement à la
était trop mignonne franchement donc
tout va bien